and we back um Strickland fight did
everybody see it yes uhhuh you see it I
did not it's okay I was reading hard for
Strickland yo it's interesting
because I didn't know that he got cut on
the eyelid like that got pretty gnarly
cut on his eyelid yeah it's really tough
like sliced open the eyelid yeah not
above like actually here I think he's
saying from headbutt so he's like he
couldn't see out of that eye before the
whole fight or for for every round that
happened after that and then uh but then
again
drus had his eye swollen by the second
so he also couldn't really see yeah
um I had drus winning the fight like I
mean pretty convincingly like to me if
Strickland won I would have called it a
bad decision Strickland stopped throwing
from the second to the fourth the fifth
he started to let it go a little bit
towards the end
but what is interesting and maybe he was
really affected by the eye but's
interesting is
like you know Strickland used the guy
like let's get in there let's bang come
on be draus stood him
up swung on him shot a bunch shot a
bunch but also he just wanted it more
like sea wasn't putting himself in
compromising situations and to me he
looked a little trigger shot he was
jabbing the guy jabbing the guy but Dr
was like I'm going to walk through the
jab I'm going to let you hit me with the
jab and then I'm going to keep coming
forward I'm going to swing and he was
like he made the fight yeah and he
outmanned him bro like I'll be honest
with you he was like I'm tougher than
you and I will prove it and he was he's
just the tougher guy he wanted it more
and he got it and are you able to pull
up some highlights he just yeah I
definitely thought Strickland won the
first and I thought dupi won the third
and fourth yeah the fifth I had
Strickland second I don't really
remember who I had win in that I think I
think I had Strickland but maybe it was
dupi but that's the round yeah it was
closer so who won dup okay yeah and was
that is that contention oh everybody
agrees okay but uh it there was a round
or two that's close but nobody was like
I nobody was like I can't believe yeah
it wasn't like a robbery yeah I Mouse
had Strickland winning clearly when we
were watching together Mouse Jones but
uh yeah I don't he definitely landed
more significant strikes but that
two-year Point might just be him eating
the jab but I I think
I maybe because I was rooting for him
because I find Strickland so funny but I
had Strickland winning yeah but that's
the white African dude right yeah oh and
he's a really interesting Fighter the
white African guy he's so uh
unconventional in the way he throws
punches yeah but even those pun I was
like they don't even look right he looks
it's like a bar fight but he's actually
quite his fight IQ is quite interesting
he's like always throwing look at that
like that's so unconventional he's
always throwing different shots from
different Ang angles he has this weird
like head kick that like comes out of
nowhere that kept catching Strickland
like it comes out of nowhere it's so
hard to Telegraph yeah or to see if it's
actually there um he just outmanned him
dude like he just out toughed him
Strickland is this great boxer he has
great jab uh really can stand right in
front of you but dup was like I'm gonna
also stand right in front of you and I'm
gonna walk through whatever punches and
Strickland doesn't have concussive power
and One D plusy was like I'll I'll let
you pepper me but I'm going to walk
through it what do you do yeah you
either got to keep peppering or you fold
and it looked for a few rounds and maybe
he was affected by the head but it
looked like he was like he's just
surviving in there now the fifth round
sh came out he [__] toughed it out it
was beautiful it was like she started
throwing these like big hay makers and
he would just bit down on that on the
mouth guard he's like I'm going to I'm
going to make this a war did you hear
what the his trainer said to him in the
corner like this is figh for that little
kid yeah this is you're fighting for
that little kid you know strick grew up
in like a super abusive household he's
like you're fighting for him right now
was a [__] moving thing dis and Then
strick Came Out Swinging but yeah just
he and it was like an awesome thing I
think it was just a little too little
too late type of thing yeah Strickland
didn't even look upset at the decision
like he's now flexed that he's upset at
it online yeah but hasn't really said it
was bad he was like if you didn't give
me that headbut he's like I could have
complained about the headbut and then it
would have ended in a no contest but the
people will deserve a fight which is
dopee like if that's why you didn't
complain about the headbutt causing the
cut which would have stopped the fight
if he actually couldn't see like the
fact he's like no I just want to fight
through it for the fans that's awesome I
also liked his last post which was like
he posted the significant strikes
numbers and his are higher in every
round he goes okay this is the last time
I'm compling I'm done now yeah so he
just like I need to get that out it's
over now let's move on next fight but
yeah in the moment he's actually very
cool too when d w first thing he did was
was he had like a gentlemen do do you
think it was just the stakes of the
situation like Strickland had everything
to lose dupes had nothing to lose and so
if they're both ready to bang like it's
every fight I've seen Strickland up
until this one he's walking the person
down he's like d walked his ass down and
yeah and to to his credit like I think
he was like I believe I can beat him and
I have everything to gain and nothing to
lose like if I lose I'd get another shot
in a couple months and I just keep it
moving so like let me just bang as hard
as I can right now where is like okay
let me keep this prevent defense but
that's the thing what makes you know the
difference what makes Champions great is
their ability to like lock in and
execute knowing that they have
everything to lose and that's a hard
thing to do really hard put on the line
when it's you have the belt so I don't
know I don't know if I tribute it to
like toughness I would just attribute to
like the stakes of the situation mental
toughness yeah but the physical
toughness of going like Strickland made
a decision I'm not going to put myself
in that compromising situations like he
could have put himself in more
compromising situations to land bigger
shots and potentially hurt the guy more
but he chose not to whereas dupi said
I'm going to put myself in incredibly
compromising situations constantly get
peppered with this jab constantly get
counter punched but I'm going to keep
coming forward and when I land he's
going to feel that [__] and he landed
the bigger shots like yeah the numbers
were off but you know Strickland is
landing that great jab but that great
jab is not stopping anybody yeah it's G
to dictate Tempo and Pace but in this
case it didn't even do that so is the
strike that significant if it's not
dictating the distance it's not
dictating the tempo and it's not
dictating the the pace how truly
significant is the jab in that regard if
it's what happens usually with
Strickland is completely mitigates the
diff the distance mhm controls where the
fight is and lets him apply pressure
that's a significant ass strike that jab
is dictating the pace of the fight yeah
but it doesn't always have to dictate if
the jab is landing that still points oh
you're right it's
absolutely if he's just Landing that at
will then and if this was like Olympic
boxing where like it literally is a
point system he wins but in like real
fighting or professional fighting you
you count the punches that are
heavier or the kicks that are heavier
that land more than a jab that's lighter
or a right hand that's lighter MH and
and and I think that's just kind of how
judges digest a fight yeah you know
they're just like oh that was a bomb
that landed that round's kind of going
in this direction yeah I think also guys
don't forget about prize picks hurry up
and sign up NFL playoffs is the best
time of the year this is what you got to
do I'm giving you my sing locks first of
all this is a four player thing so it's
a four player pick so if you hit you can
to make you can make some cash off of
prize picks first of all Isaiah Pacho
will get more than 63 half rushing yards
Patrick Mahomes will get more than 248
and a half passing yards Travis Kelce I
love you I love what you're doing with
Taylor Swift but I think you're going to
get less than 65 receiving yards and
Lamar Jackson MVP I think you're going
to get more than 212 passing yards and
sign up for priz picks.com use that
promo code Schulz they will match your
initial deposit up to $100 so you put in
100 you 100 for free now let's get back
to the exclusive patreon clip if you
want the full episode go to
they don't tell you stay in the pocket
keep keep it up you're killing it great
job keep up the good work
so but yeah I like I would watch it
again they promoted the [__] out of the
fight I thought it was great apparently
the biggest gate they have had ever like
oh really apparently like the like
biggest opening gate I'm pretty sure I
don't know total pay-per-view but wow I
think VA was telling me that like the
opening was the biggest they've had or
some [__] wow I didn't know I mean it
was I mean Toronto's just awesome like
great fans like and strickly just has a
hold on the culture like I've never seen
like since Connor I guess like in terms
of like adoration I mean I don't he
hasn't had the longevity that Conor had
but just in terms of like grip on the
fan base being recklessly yourself is
intoxicating but he's a specific he's
like what Colby Covington wants to be H
like Colby Covington is like riding the
Maga wave and as part of the Maga wave
he's taking shots of the people that
like Trump would take shots at and like
trying to speak in that way and then
Strickland is doing it but he's not a
character yeah everybody knows col's
like playing up a character so they like
feeling their sentiments echoed by a
famous person who's a fighter but at the
same time they're like you don't really
maybe believe this maybe you do I don't
know I can't trust it Strickland you're
like yo this guy believes this [__] this
guy's like done with the LG BBQ he's
done with trans disc like he's done like
he's done with true do he's done with
like he's and he'll call it out and I
think all those people who are frust i'
really enjoy you know feeling heard and
seen yeah yeah it was Strickland and
Theo they did something recently right
yeah yeah where where Strickland was
crying yeah but he is still playing a
character cuz he he's like leaning into
I think what Strickland is is he's he's
an internet dude and he's absorbed some
YouTube and and you know social media
videos and learn some stuff about what's
happening culturally through those
videos so he knows like the buzzwords
they philosophically resonate with him
but I don't know if he's going to like
break down a nuanced way of like why Dei
is bad mhm but he will be like not every
Disney movie needs to have a gay scene
that's what you guys are doing and then
everybody who's frustrated by Disney is
like he's speaking out for us which is
kind of what we're saying about v v
might talk over you they strick going to
talk on the level where you're I that's
a he's going to speak for the people who
are quote unquote disenfranchised
they're not really disenfranchised but
they feel like no mainstream media
Outlet is going to Echo their sentiments
and all of a sudden he's on them echoing
them and not backing down yeah and yeah
was like he he had everybody going yeah
yeah I want to see him win just to see
the train keep going I want to see where
that ride would go like if he keeps
winning and keeps on talking [__] like
he's only going to get more confident oh
yeah you know what I mean like he's only
going to talk more [__] yeah like I
don't even think this is going to slow
him down and I think Dana sees his value
to the UFC 100% and how good he can
build a fight like he'll get paid off
this forever yeah you know what I mean
that's the beauty of the UFC even though
he lost the the belt he's still going to
make crazy bread just getting fights
with other guys in the in the division
there's a huge rematch fight with Izzy
yeah uh so the white African call out is
he the white African now I think UFC 300
the white African cuz I can't
pronounce DDP the white African there go
the white African and Izzy might fight
at UFC 300 they're I think they're
looking for like a headliner for UFC 300
I mean that' be great of course I'm a
huge and then the rematch is with
Strickland no matter who's there yeah
now where what weight division is
chimaya
in Chimay is uh because I think he's in
that weight division right he's fighting
at
185 middleweight yeah so he he wants a
title shot yeah so who knows maybe that
title shot is against
drus yeah and you know it's different
jamv can can can punch yeah and he can
punch yeah I want Izzy to take a little
more time off selfishly as a friend keep
resting up yeah but it's it's hard you
know it's seductive to get out there in
them lights again yeah Hamza already
wants to plus these he already like
talked about wanting to be the headliner
for 300 yeah I don't know if he's big
enough for the headlining fight I think
you need star power you need Connor you
need Izzy you need Jon Jones like you
need is Conor confirmed for a comeback
fight by the way which in
there I can't believe I mean like after
just learning more things that we
learned I cannot believe Connor is
fighting ever again what more things did
you learn just how much money he's
actually made oh you just said it it's
seductive the lights you're right there
so according to this proper 12 he took
in 600 million from his uh EG just him
holy [__] just him not he sold his steak
which was 50% for 600
million yeah okay just
him that's crazy plus all the fight
purses like he's had like three of the
biggest think about the McGregor fight
oh
insane Floyd Mayweather FL oh Floyd [__]
yeah wow God
yeah his fight earnings uh he ended up
richer than Floyd looking here at even
just his fight earnings 31 million for
participation in nine UFC bouts in which
he won
eight so like 150 off Floyd wait a minut
he's lost his last
like yeah the only guy he beat was
cowboy zerone in the
last yeah yeah I don't know when this
was published and before that he beat
Diaz but then lost to Diaz before that
right uh so he's he's won two out of his
last like seven eight fights
yeah don't matter don't matter wait
maybe it's more yeah I mean he's I mean
he's made so much money shout out to you
bro but that so that's the thing it's
like why would he ever come back like
you must need the lights yeah right yeah
well you enjoy it yeah you do have a
goal a purpose just like moving towards
something enjoy Combat Sports like it's
like you go play padle you enjoy that
[__] no you're right also spar with much
less
stress some like he's not he's not
trying to go pro I don't think I'm going
to go pro yeah trying to get get play
paddle the other day you know what he
wor my professional paddle
t-shirt what is a professional paddle
t-shirt I mean it's a Team USA
professional paddle
t-shirt and I worn by the United States
team for paddle and I looked at him I
was like there's no [__] way you're
wearing that dumbass and then behind him
Jason unzips his jacket matching Jersey
yeah cuz we're a team did you guys win
you guys are
C this [__]
is I need that
picture I give a picture die laugh it
dud but I'm going to take kamaro to go
play wait really yeah has he ever played
before no but he's in town that's pretty
fire so he's like cuz he plays pickle
and he was and he's like yo I want to
play Let's oh pickle I heard you can get
injured playing pickle I know Guy tour
is Joy Avery and he's like an athletic
kid but he be tearing everything like he
stays [__] his ankles up has huge uh
injury issue yeah because everybody's 90
yeah yeah it's all people stopping for
the first time in a long time you just
stand right on that line pickle sucks a
dick anyway I have an unnecessary amount
of like a IR towards pickle because
everybody confuses paddle of pickle and
Pickle's so popular and it sucks dick
we're paddle supremacist yeah we are
gotta got you did do you want to say the
name of the paddle Brands yeah paddle
files or paddle
filia I like that what is happening it's
the name of a new mil million dollar
brand that we're going to exit you're
saying you wouldn't buy you wouldn't buy
something from a company called paddle
filia is paddle popular in Australia
no wait how' you answer that is paddle
popular in no yeah it's not Spain I'm
trying to see if even then I'm pretty
sure Spain is like oh that [__] it's
Spain and flagrant I'm trying to see if
it's so the Olympics it won't make the
Paris Olympics they're already that's
[__] up dude Olympics in America are
2028 in La make you can compete you can
petition I'm going to personally Lobby
for paddle to be in the Olympics in 2028
is La you can petition yeah I will make
sure and you're going to be in there at
a 45-year-old Olympian I think what I'll
do is I'll either compete or I will
announce oh that's fun yeah I will
announce for the Spanish broadcast okay
oh yeah I like that and they probably
aren't any Spanish speakers who know
more about paddle than you I wouldn't
think so not on my level not my session
not my proximity to the game the passion
you got the passion is there yeah I mean
like he told me yesterday before the
party goes this is unlike anything I've
ever experienced like the level of
obsession it's unlike anything only
stand up only stand up have I been this
obsessed about something wow it's kind
of crazy he's going to go
pro suck today man if you go pro then
I'll respect it hey hey you know what we
bombed us some open mics can I be honest
with you guys I don't think I'm going
pro man
no I can't after today I was so bad
today wen't there nights where you're
like maybe I won't make it as a comedian
no